via sa belle nico va merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en direct sur
rt france alors ses relations tendues
entre les deux pays ne date pas d'hier
pourquoi finalement le noeud du problème
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
persiste encore aujourd'hui c'est un
conflit qui comme vous avez bien dit de
longue durée qui n'était pas encore
résolue malgré les quatre résolutions
des nations unies malgré les les
reconnaissances des payer comme quoi
c'est le territoire d'azerbaïdjan le
conflit reste aux journaux résolu malgré
le cessez le feu qui était proclamée en
1994 entre les deux parties le contrôle
continu et là tout ce que s'est passé
cette semaine il a onze morts en
azerbaïdjan et d'une grande
manifestation d'un coup pour la
situation est super super tendu et
pourquoi la situation s'envenime tel
maintenant je pense que c'était une
provocation de côté arménien ans parce
que en plus ne sais même pas ce n'est
même pas à la frontière du haut-karabakh
c'est entre la frontière du tout vous
entre la frontière de la faune entre la
frontière de l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie
est assez loin du look à rabat et c
était la provocation pure des arts
millions elles avaient ils ont tué
d'abord deux officiers il avait après à
quatre morts quelques planer et entre
temps il avait entre hautement entre les
deux parties et à ce jeu là il ya des
morts et en civil de côté armel kana
qu'est ce qui a déclenché finalement ces
opérations militaires côté arménien
pensées et ses situations même
d'actualité un peu longue et difficile à
dire
ce que je sais il avait une voiture qui
était en train de vérifier ses
frontières c'était un passage quotidien
on peut le vérifier les frontières d'un
coup ils avaient en attaque par mignan
qui ont commencé à attaquer cette
voiture là et ça crée un conflit une
immense tensions entre les deux pays à
qui a causé le mort des gens non
coupable mais la session les situations
les super tendu dans l'azerbaïdjan elle
est super tendu qu'on le voyait sur la
vidéo est là et là une grande
manifestation à bakou les gens les gens
souhaitent récupérer à le territoire du
haut karabagh alors on l'a vu une
situation tendue qui inquiète également
la communauté internationale comment
est-ce que la russie se positionne sur
le dossier messieurs la fossella il a
bien précisé pas la russie l'a bien
précisé comme quoi il faut absolument
arrêter le compte les arrêter
concrètement il faut repartir sur la
négociation des dossiers sion
diplomatique mais l'ignorent clients et
là aussi bon en gros c'est caucase du
sud elle se trouve dans la région entre
la russie la turquie les rangs c'est un
région et c'est assez importante et il
ce conflit là et il la personne qu'elle
est en ville à avoir le conflit dans
cette région
mais comme dit c'est un conflit pas de
date récente c'est un conflit de longue
durée
quel jusqu'au là on n'arrive pas à
trouver la solution et comme vous le
savez il allait en groupe de minsk qui
depuis 1914 et s'est trouvé la solution
est là n'avaient pas mal des meetings
pas mal des déclarations qui était fait
mais on est en 2020 ben et jusqu'au là
on a toujours les morts malheureusement
dans cette région en tout cas on
continuera à suivre la situation de très
près merci à vous au lia chavel nico va
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes historienne et
spécialiste des
du caucase du sud